looking at me now you could probably
have a decent go at describing me but
what about now you might remember more
or less that I have pale skin and dark
hair but what if I asked you to describe
my nose would you say it was flat long
pointy and what about my eyes round
almond-shaped wide set deep set close
together difficult to be specific isn't
it and that gives you some indication of
the kinds of problems that detectives
face when they're trying to recreate
images of suspects
the idea behind police sketches is
simple and eye witness sees a crime and
works with the police to create an image
of the criminal but how accurate are
these kinds of sketches do they really
help catch criminals experiments by
forensic psychologists in the UK found
that faces were identified correctly by
police sketches in just a percent of
cases there have been some cases where
police sketches have worked well such as
the Oklahoma bomber Timothy McVeigh and
the sketch of serial killer Ted Bundy
which prompted people who knew Bundy to
call the authorities but more often than
not the similarities are not that close
and a police sketch ends up being mostly
a guesstimate and one reason it's so
difficult to get them right is because
our brains aren't wires to process each
individual feature on a face when the
mind remembers a face it doesn't look at
the face and break it up into databases
of noses and eyes and ears and then try
to reconstruct them which is how the
early systems work instead when we look
at faces we remember the whole face so
our mind is restoring the face
holistically when it comes to police
sketches the process of reconstructing a
face from memory detail by detail is the
opposite of how we naturally recall
faces in the 60s and 70s systems such as
identikit and photofit tried to fix this
problem with large databases of
interchangeable features by the 80s
computerized systems such as e-fit meant
they could be a bit more customized but
the witness still had to scroll through
lists of individual features so any fate
constructed was limited by those options
these aren't the only hurdles not only
do we find it difficult to identify
individual features we also struggle to
describe them so when you see the face
of a perpetrator if you're unlucky
enough to be a witness to a crime you
see the face so it's visual but when the
police officer asks you to describe it
you have to give a verbal response and
our brains aren't very good at swapping
between modalities swapping from the
visual to the verbal then there's the
issue of time the problem is is that
witnesses are normally interviewed a
couple of days or a week after a crime
and where this happens
witnesses struggle to her and what the
face looks like and they struggle to
remember the parts of the face and what
we know is for unfamiliar faces our
memory tends to be particularly good for
the hair and the outer part of the face
and yet when you become familiar with a
face it's the central internal features
and you tend to rely on in order to be
able to recognize somebody's faces so a
witness will tend to construct the outer
part of the face well but somebody who's
trying to recognize the face will be
looking at the central part of the face
and so there's a kind of a mismatch in
what's accurate in the face and that's
what has led to Evo fit a composite
facial system that Charlie Froude helped
to develop it presents randomly
generated faces that users are able to
tweak adjusting them by variables such
as pleasantness attractiveness or
honesty we built a system that shows
witnesses screens of faces and they're
asked to select faces that look like the
person that they've seen those choices
are then combined together and another
screen is produced in some of the
experiments what we've been doing is
showing witnesses faces where the outer
part is de-emphasize all blurred to help
a witness focus on the central part of
the face and that's actually quite
effective to help people construct the
central part of the face more accurate
and so produce a more identifiable
composite we've shown in the laboratory
identification can be about 75 percent
correct I mean so performance that
really is quite good and actually
valuable for police and for policing Evo
fit helped catch a serial rapist in
Manchester who was recognized by a
facial composite on crime watch and
turned in to the police by his own
brother very often perhaps the facial
composite images aren't that accurate
but nonetheless they can be an
invaluable prompt to somebody who maybe
looks at it and thinks is that someone I
know and that can be all that's needed
to push them over the line and call the
police and say I think it's this person